la planta nuclear más grande de europa
está en poder de rusia desde hace
semanas bombardeos han impactado los
alrededores pero quien está bombardeando
ambos lados se acusan mutuamente de
atacar constantemente la planta
kiev continúa su provocación para
amenazarnos con un desastre nuclear en
sap orilla
esta guerra de la información también se
puede escuchar desde el lado ucraniano
la planta fue impactada seguramente sí
pero no está claro dónde exactamente
dentro del perímetro de seguridad hay
seis reactores y áreas dedicadas al
combustible usado y a los desechos
nucleares los reactores están protegidos
pero hasta cierto punto
y
los edificios de contención que son
cúpulas de hormigón están ahí para
proteger el núcleo del reactor así como
la piscina donde se almacena el
combustible gastado los protegen por
ejemplo de un accidente aéreo pero no
han sido diseñados para los riesgos de
bombardeo en tiempo
bajo aunque algunas áreas de la central
nuclear no están tan protegidas porque
son menos peligrosas hay riesgo de
contaminación
antes
de un ataque en un área de
almacenamiento de residuos podría llevar
a una difusión más limitada y local unos
kilómetros quizás pero no al nivel
nacional o continental
a nivel nacional
total por el momento la agencia de
seguridad nuclear francesa afirma que no
registraron un aumento de radioactividad
en el área